for certain individuals and you want
guidance for them you know you you want
the best for humanity right and that's
real love so if you were to hang out now
with somebody whose life is just he
talks about openly about
you know doing drugs and testified a
couple days ago that you had done just
about every kind of drug there was by
age
13 or 14 right 15 15. and you've
um
you found that drugs are the only way to
numb your pain
right
they've always been um a medicine from a
yes a numbing agent and you said
yesterday that in fact i i think you
said you take drugs to numb the demons
right
i don't know that i said to numb the
demons but i have well
if i did say demons drinking
and and you would sometimes drink
whiskey in the mornings too right
during this time period um
i i
i you know i mean isn't happy hour any
time
and that cocaine that those white lines
those are coca that's cocaine right
i would assume yeah and that's that's
your cocaine that you kept in that box
that says property of jd with the skull
and crossbones isn't it well the
beautiful composition of the photograph
would suggest that certainly and he's
kind he's going through so much now mr
johnny depp right
is that the kind of like when we look
back at your life
you know what you were you know going
through that wildness and do you think
now if he just
did what you were doing like connecting
it with the prayer just putting your
head down on the ground you know you
know beseeching health from the crater
that runs into earth you know you think
this would help you know if you can get
some of what you got now you know that
priceless gift that money can't buy but
you can get it for free
what would you say to someone if you're
hanging out with someone like johnny
depp and he's going to you see what he's
going through right now i was a mess i
was a wreck i was
shaking and
i just didn't understand why
um and then i
looked down
and realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my bones
his cigarette
and and um
this is after the finger had
gone away
um and she stubbed it out in my in in in
my face and on my cheek didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know even a lot of fights been around a
long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not deck you i
was hitting you i don't know what the
motion of my actual hand was but you're
fine i did not hurt you i did not punch
you i was hitting you johnny physical
fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
well you know it's funny because
what led me to islam
besides meeting you know the um
influential of the few influential
people in my in my life um that helped
me
uh learn and and step into um
to islam was
you know trying to help myself i read
many many self-help books you know read
so many
um
but
you know some of tony robbins
oh everything everything everything i've
read about 30 books i'd say when i was
going through my struggles but then when
i found islam i was like
subhanallah like this
caters for all of those books in one you
know
so for me i would say
in terms of the struggles that we have
in the dunya the kryptonite
is the quran and the hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him you know
whether it is
you know like for example sallah you
talk about sallah
you know i'm a bit of a deep thinker so
when i think about sallah i think about
five times and i put it in the context
of the self-help book because you know
not everyone for us when we're talking
it's easy because alhamdulillah you know
our point of reference is what
in the guidance that we have but when
you're talking to a non-believer or
someone that doesn't know islam
i always try and put it into that
context where i was when i was a little
bit lost or searching for something
because subhanallah how we've been
created we all want to belong we all
search for something you know they say
or mid-life crisis or whatever it is you
come to a point everyone comes to a
point where they're like what is this
world what is this
the only thing in this life is certain
is death so why am i actually here you
know
but just that point sallah
five times a day i would say five times
a day i strive to pray with my heart not
just my limbs and when you're doing that
when you're in the most vulnerable
position you can be hit and saju it's
beautiful
you know
um
in that position
naturally you're and and you you're
doing it with the sincerity in your
heart naturally you're grateful for
whatever you have
you know
it might be just that little date that
you get to have
during during ramadan and in a glass of
water so that little date tastes like
the the best food you've ever had as you
know bro you know so like for me
being in sahaja yog
or making salah with my heart i'm
grateful i'm grateful you know for
everything i'm you know
i'm grateful for the wealth allah has
given me you know because it's allowed
me to help my close ones it's allowed me
to live a life that
and affect people in the way that i
would love to affect people and
i think humbly for the for for the
blessings of my children you know that
um to be
to be a uh anyone can be a anyone you
know a lot of people can be parents
but
it takes time and effort and persistence
to be a great parent or a good parent
you know so
you know just things like that like i
sit there and and those are the things
that you think of or that i when i was
reading about reading the self out books
was you know you should
implement a bit of um
you know uh
contemplate during the day or think
about things that show the gratitude
aspect of life we tick all of those
boxes we took a lot of these things when
we pray for and we do it five times a
day
you know um so that's the things i would
probably say to johnny depp is
uh
you know
keep an open mind
and just have a read you know just
just have a reader